No. Shopping, food.
-Theatre…
-Drinks.
-D***
D**** bum sex.
D**** bum sex!
D**** d**** bum sex!
We write the power
into music.
Let's do it.
Anyway, no, no, no.
Dating.
Hi, everyone!
It's The Vivienne.
And look who's back!
It's me, the mediocre queen,
Cheryl Hole! Yes!
And we are…
Queens who like to watch!
Yeah, we really rehearsed
that, didn't we?
Today, divas,
we are watching
the brand new dating show
Sexy Beasts,
which is obviously
a dating show,
but you can't see
their faces
because they're
under prosthetics
as sexy beasts.
-What she said.
-Yeah.
Have you missed me?
I have.
-I'll drink to that.
-Cheers, sweetie.
Cheers, thanks a lot.
I am so single
I'm dressed as a panda bear
to try to find a connection
with somebody.
Oh no, I don't like it.
Look at the eyes.
How good are those masks?
What would your mask be?
A f****** star!
Still flogging
that dead horse.
Are they on the set
of Drag Race UK?
Could you fall in love
with someone
based on personality alone?
Ass first,
personality second.
That was made
before veneers.
Who is coming up
with this stuff?
I mean, there's
definitely been some…
…going on here.
I do love the panda, though.
I feel like
if I could really bond
with someone's personality,
their sense of humour,
that could actually be
something that sticks
because I'm clearly doing
this dating thing all wrong.
But if they're all dead fit
underneath it anyway,
it kind of defeats
the object.
There's got to be
a couple of mingers.
Oh yeah, you got to get
to the end and go…
"Oh… Is that it?"
Maybe get like a cash prize
and a box of Viagra
just in case
they are minging.
Don't try and trigger me
with cash prizes.
Girl! You've won
more than I have!
Three batches and a crown!
I am ready to find
my future husband,
someone who's maybe
as fun and klutzy
and goofy as I am.
Are you a goofball?
I am a bit of a goofball.
You a goofball?
I am a bit of a goofball!
We're a couple of goofballs.
Oh, I've missed you.
I'm a bit obsessed already.
Look,
I'm very invested already
because I love
a production value
and clearly
these prosthetics…
Is it "prosthetics"?
Proth-thetics.
The gin's kicked in already,
darling!
Prosthetics, dear.
Prosthetics.
Pros…
Prosy-thetics.
Pros-the-sis.
We got there in the end.
Put your teeth in, girl.
Done.
…starting with Ethan.
Oh, look at the Tin Man.
Do you think his jaw's
like that underneath
and that's why
they gave him that mask?
Yeah, he's got a huge jaw.
Like that.
I play underwater hockey,
I free-dive…
Underwater hockey?
Right. I don't know
what the straights
get up to these days,
but that's definitely
something new, right?
Next up is Tyler, a model.
-Oh, I love that one.
-A model.
Hang on, this isn't fair.
Pause it, pause it.
This isn't fair. Hang on.
You can see
he's got a dead ripped body.
They should have padded
the bodies out as well.
-Look--
-Because all the girls
will be like, "Look at
the f****** pecs on him!"
It's the tits show.
I like the tits on the head.
See, that could be hiding
a huge conehead.
I know what it takes to win.
I know who I am.
-And I--
-I don't know like people
when they're, like,
do something fun,
-they box, they're like…
-Yeah.
Hoping you don't…
Whoa!
Are they his real eyes?
Do his eyes look that close
together 'cause of the mask?
I… Right, Viv--
I'm not saying anything else
'cause once his mask
comes off,
I'm gonna get cancelled,
aren't I?
Weren't you already?
Oh, I'd love a girl that's
into Marvel and Star Wars
and could also match me
in my Funko Pop! collection.
Oh, he does look fabulous.
He does sound
like he's got hay fever.
He's got
a Funko Pop! collection.
Viv, how would you
describe yourself
if you were on
a dating show,
not that you would,
you're a married lady.
"Cross-dressing shoplifter
looking for a good time."
What about you?
"Gin and Botox, advised."
"6.5 out of 10,
ready to suck you off."
I'm just j…
if I was on
the receiving end
of listening to your VT,
I'd think you were bad news.
She's a party girl
from Essex.
I'm not a party girl
anymore though!
Oh, yeah.
She's been locked up.
They won't let me out.
But anyway,
Carousel will now speed date
all three boys.
I wish they'd sent them
to the cinema
without letting anyone else
in the cinema know.
Imagine sitting there,
f****** panda
and the alien walked in.
"Shall we go for a drink?"
"What the f***'s
going on here?"
Where are you from,
Carousel? Don't tell me.
The zoo.
Good one, Dad!
She's too much for me.
I can't bear her.
A lot of my friends call me
the real life Aquaman.
Aquaman?
I can hold my breath
for like four minutes.
He'd be great
for Kim Kardashian
now she's single.
When she drops a diamond
earring into the sea again,
he could go and find it.
-Ever cheated?
-No, never.
Do you have a lot of
followers on Instagram?
-No.
-Uh, no.
I'm sorry, if anybody cares
about how many followers
you have,
-tap out.
-Ever have a threesome?
I…
I have kissed multiple girls
at the same time.
Why does that alien sound
like Michael Jackson?
"I kissed girls at the same
time, I'm not gonna lie."
Blanket! Blanket!
Honestly, I'm sure that's
Michael Jackson in the mask.
Well, I'm pretty sure
Michael Jackson's
not actually dead.
He's not, he's there.
Did you not see the video
of him jumping out that car?
-When?
-So, the coroner came
and then there's a video
of what looks like
Michael Jackson leaving…
-There's not.
-…and going into a building.
-Girl, that was Janice.
-Janice?
Control!
What have you done
For me lately?
This is literally
the future!
I'm sorry,
I can't get over it.
They literally looked like
they were on the main stage.
Do you know what?
If I had to get rid of one,
I'd probably get rid
of the muscle hunk.
I'd get rid of that panda
straight away.
She's like this…
She's picking.
-Oh, she's picking?
-Yeah.
We've gotta get rid
of the boysies.
Can we not find
a new candidate?
'Cause I can't watch
a series with her.
She got the shittest outfit
as well.
That's why she's fuming.
They went to Primark
and went,
what black rollneck
can we get?
Who we getting rid of?
We're keeping Tin Man.
We're keeping
the Taurus Bull.
And we'll get rid
of Green Fingers.
But no, because I like
the look of his mask.
It's not about the mask,
it's about the person.
Good bone structure
under there.
See, I'm going for…
I'm being shallow already.
You are. You're basing it
off appearance,
which is what
the mask is for!
-Just take the masks off--
-Close your eyes.
This next round, close
your eyes and just listen.
We'll do audio description
for you.
Now we're doing
The Masked Singer,
Dancer Date and The Voice.
We should pitch that
to Netflix.
The Masked Voice Date
Thing Show.
We'll workshop the title,
Viv.
Stakes could not
be higher…
It seems like a lot
to come to England
just to use a nice house.
They could do it
at that place
where they filmed
the G.U.Y. music video,
that castle.
Gorgeous.
…real face.
You have no clue
what I'm on about, do you?
-Yeah, the Gaga video?
-Yeah.
Just the way you looked
at me and went,
"Gorgeous".
I'm just looking at you.
I'm just mesmerised.
Ethan, I love
how genuine you are.
"Genuine."
Is she French now?
Genuine.
Tyler, you are my type
to a T.
Look at his smile!
Girl, that wasn't that…
That's a Botox smile,
it's so…
I love that you're a nerd.
I wish I could go on
a second date with you all.
No, you don't.
Why are you lying?
…gonna have to let
one of you go.
And that person is…
Ethan.
Yay!
-I'm confused.
-I'm not surprised.
F****** dodged a bullet
there, lad.
So, he's got the chop?
I was hoping
she would eliminate me.
I mean…
Where's the button?
Won't be bothered
if he's good-looking
because a man
that is excited
to not be with me anymore
is not a man
I'm attracted to anymore.
I don't think she read
the job description.
No, she just wants
a bit of d****.
Thanks to some quick work
with a can opener,
we can see that
he is good-looking.
Viv, when are you
gonna take your mask off?
I can't,
it's under the epidermis,
so it's been injected in.
Spilt in.
Oh my God! You're so…
How long
do you think they waited
for them to take
all the prosthetics off?
What better way to encourage
panda-alien love
than a romantic date…
-Oh!
-…axe throwing?
Throw it here.
That's too much cardio
for me.
Aim for the panda!
So, basically,
I'm steaming hot right now.
Yeah, okay.
Gonna start to add jokes.
She's just perving my head
out by the minute.
I brought my homeboy just
in case things went south.
Okay, just in case
she was ugly.
No! Just in case
I got catfished!
Nowadays you don't know.
If that's your
worst date story,
someone asked me
to pee on them.
If you're into it,
go for it.
Are you into…
No, we're oversharing.
We should make a bet
or something.
I hit the bullseye
next throw.
What are the stakes of that?
I might get to take you
on another date maybe.
Where you gonna take her?
The zoo?
Drop her off
at Edinburgh Zoo.
Lock her in.
I fed a tiger the other day.
Was it in captivity?
-Was it?
-I just went to the Amazon.
Was it in captivity?
Hansel Cheryl.
Cheryl believes in putting
animals in captivity.
It was at a zoo!
Viv just wants me gone.
-No, I'm having a ball.
-Bring back beggar.
At the moment, Tyler's
my potential husband.
I think he was my type
to a T,
but I feel like
I'm not getting all of him.
You're throwing us off the
scent, you're all over him.
I dunno!
It's like people
that have already decided
they want a cheeseburger
when there's
a mayo chicken there.
But spend an hour looking
through the menu anyway.
What shall I have?
No, you'd decided you want
the double ched-bomb.
What's the worst date
you've ever been on?
I think the worst date
I've ever been on
is one that I didn't even
realise was a date.
I thought we were friends.
And then we turned up
to this bar and he was like,
"I just bought
this bottle of wine."
And I was like,
"Lovely! Lovely!"
He's like, "Just bought
another bottle."
I was like, "Lovely!
I'm getting very drunk."
But lo and behold,
he's like,
"Oh no, you've missed
the last train.
You're gonna have
to come back to mine."
-I was like--
-I think you got kidnapped.
And then he was like…
making the move.
I was like, I didn't realise
it was going like this.
Two bottles deep and wine,
I was like, d'you know what?
Let's just roll with it.
Then I was like, "Actually,
I want to go home."
And he was like,
"You can't go home."
I hate to break this to you,
I think you got kidnapped.
The way…
When you put it like that,
I think I actually was!
Oh my God, that's so cute.
The party motivator scene
would do numbers
if you brought
a pet meerkat.
Yeah, I think…
Oh, look! A meerkat!
Oh my God, they're
feeding the meerkats.
She's a lot taller than him.
Oh, he's sat down.
I could never get
with anybody shorter than me
because I just find it very
uncomfortable being on top.
Why? You a top queen, girl?
I'm not a top queen.
-Are you not?
-I get on top.
Oh right, okay.
So you're a bottom?
-Viv…
-But you get on top?
How long
have you known me?
Yeah, but I don't think
we've ever had this chat.
So Cheryl's a bottom?
Exclusive.
I'm the top but I bottomed
the other day for David.
-What?
-I don't know what it is
about this living room that
just makes me overshare…
everything.
It's good company,
good television
and good drinks,
that's what does it to you.
I accept.
There's Cheryl,
feeding the tigers.
Breakfast!
If you could be a lion,
a tiger or a bear,
which one would you be?
I'd be a bear,
just so I could say, "Hiya,
I'm a bear!" every day.
Let me just, like,
tidy up my nose.
Look at him trying to drink
through that.
Right, this is like
drag queens
trying to drink
on a night out.
Give the boy a straw!
Reusable.
I'm like, I need to, like,
touch you a little bit,
see what the vibes are?
-Excuse me.
-She's too much, isn't she?
Has there ever been
a dating show
where they've got
to the next round and go,
"Actually,
I can't stand her."
Yeah, like Dinner Date,
ever watched Dinner Date?
That happens quite a lot
on there. They're like,
"God, I can't bear him.
Hope he doesn't choose me."
I felt a really good
connection with Josh today.
You'd feel a good connection
with a tree, love.
She's just looking
in the mirror.
"Oh, I've got a great
connection with you."
I'm not playing around,
my future husband is here.
All she's done is talk about
getting married, wrong show!
Why doesn't she go on
Married at First Sight?
Say yes to the dress.
Will she go
for wild and crazy?
Girl, you'd better be a lot
'cause I want a lot!
Or safe and sensible?
-You have life insurance?
-Yeah.
Okay.
I'm not gonna lie, Viv,
out of these two,
I'm going with Mr Bull.
I, um…
I think we'd have a laugh.
But the thing is, you could
tell he let his guard down
from the get-go.
He jumped over the…
What?
Have I just changed?
I said I'll go with him
because we'd have a laugh.
-You--
-And not the guy
with the obviously nice body
under there.
Thank you Netflix
for changing The Vivienne.
This show is working, oo-er!
She's such a shallow b****
that I think
she's gonna go
with the alien
because she could see
the Titicacas
out of his little roll-neck.
I think she'd pick herself
if she had the opportunity.
I don't know whether
it's the mask or the hair
or the bowl or the nose,
but it's doing something
so strange to his face.
Well, he's got no forehead.
His forehead's
been taken away.
But I've got good eyebrows
underneath all this.
The eyes are all like…
You can't move
your forehead.
What forehead?
I just want the reveal,
that's all I want.
Bring it on.
Hey, guys!
See, even the alien mask
is still quite sexy,
then he's sat there
as a bull like that.
My sexy beast
and future husband is…
Tyler.
Let's go!
Look, we all saw it.
The writing was on the wall.
She was gonna pick him.
Yeah, but there
might be a big gag.
We all think he's
a sexy alien at this point.
Till that mask comes off,
it's anyone's game, innit?
-Yeah, exactly.
-And what's stopping her?
If he's a minger under that,
she'll just f****** go
to the thing
at the end of the day,
that's a wrap everyone,
well done.
She'll just get in his car
and go back to the hotel.
When's the wedding?
The poor Taurus is still
sat there watching them.
-What?
-Looks like Rebecca More!
Well,
I wasn't expecting that.
I was getting brunette vibes
from her.
See, I was getting blonde.
-I would.
-I wasn't expecting that.
Sadly, Carousel
has blown her chance
of dating
a real-life Clark Kent.
The glasses made it.
He needs a couple
of eye drops, though.
Yeah.
Prosthetics done wonders
for him.
I could see into the eyes
of the panda mask
that she was gonna be
an attractive girl.
I don't know why
I wanna cry.
It's hard because it's like
I came here for love.
She wants his d**** now?
-Why is she crying?
-You've had your chance.
Get a grip, sweetie!
If she's crying
over a f****** bull,
imagine her trying to make
life-changing decisions.
He's got a much softer face
than what I thought.
Know what I mean?
It was like the angles
of the prosthetic.
Yeah, I thought he was
gonna be dead chiselled.
Was I what
you were expecting?
Better than I expected.
He doesn't seem
as much as a d****
without the prosthetics on.
It's like us in drag.
Awkward and…
-He was just in drag.
-Well, that's it, yeah.
-Billy Big Bollocks.
-Took his armour off.
I think the mask off was…
heaven,
and a little bit of a kiss,
that was heaven too.
She's getting rattled
tonight.
Just leave the bottle
of poppers on the sofa.
She's not gonna wait
for the hotel,
find the nearest bush.
You know
on Naked Attraction
when they f***
the night after the day?
That's what's gonna
happen now.
Yeah, never see
each other again.
Yeah, one month later.
Yeah.
What a waste
of proth-thetics.
Proth-thetics!
I'm ready to mingle.
Oh my God!
I want that one!
If he doesn't like me
for me, it's not worth it.
That is amazing.
These… this make-up
is fantastic.
I'm actually quite into it.
I think it's
a really good show.
I love anything that's got
like a gag and a reveal.
-Yeah.
-And whatever.
Because you're invested,
you wanna know
what happens.
Keeps you
right till the end.
Well, there's stakes
to play for.
If I were single,
I would 100% go on this
just for banter.
I don't think
I'd ever go on it.
So it's a guessing game,
there's a good reveal in it,
it's a dating show,
all rolled into one.
It's a winner.
You just loved slagging
the girl off.
Yeah, and I'd stand by that,
she was a knobhead.
Carousel?
If she was born in the UK,
she'd be called
Merry-Go-Round.
You f****** idiot.
I love you.
Well, there we have it,
Sexy Beast.
It's a big thumbs-up
from me. What about you?
I'd give two thumbs-up
from Chezzy.
So I've been The Vivienne…
And I've been Cheryl Hole.
Don't forget to catch me
next time,
and who will be
on the couch?
Not you! Bye!
Bye!
You sounded
like Basil Brush then.